- [Voiceover] I cry
every time my mother says
she's proud of my weight loss.
She still doesn't know I'm anorexic.
(exotic chiming music)
- [Voiceover] Whenever my
boyfriend sees my body,
I'm scared that he'll notice I'm anorexic.
- [Voiceover] I tell people
I'm on a liquid diet.
What they don't realize
is that I'm anorexic,
and the only liquid in my diet is water.
- [Voiceover] I have anorexia.
My head keeps telling me,
pretty girls don't eat.
- [Voiceover] I'm anorexic.
I hate myself with a passion.
The only time I eat is
when I'm going drinking,
because being drunk is the only thing
that takes away the pain.
- [Voiceover] I only eat
in front of my parents
so they won't find out I'm anorexic
and send me to recovery.
- [Voiceover] I tell
everyone I'm losing weight
because I exercise,
but the truth is I'm anorexic.
- [Voiceover] I'm anorexic
and I'm trying to get better.
I can't stand that every
restaurant displays calories.
It's so triggering.
- [Voiceover] I denied the
fact that I have anorexia.
Today I saw my sister start to
hate on her body the way I do.
She's eight, this really hit home.
I need to change for her sake.
- [Voiceover] I recovered
from anorexia four years ago.
I used to pray to God
that he would let me die.
But surviving has made
me a stronger person.
I'm proud of who I've become.
(ambient music)
(creaky swiveling)